[Musique]
arthur ashe bonjour bonjour vous ne
pouvez pas vous empêcher de jouer du
piano banon se met derrière un piano ça
se joue entièrement mes plus sincères
condoléances
merci dans l'escalier en avril dernier
votre père jacky j'ai nous quitter ouais
un drame pour ses admirateurs et
admiratrices pour son fils qu'est ce que
ça représentait en fait qu'on les gens
meurent
ils nous font le cadeau de leur esprit
donc déjà on ne la fait un très beau
départ enterrement de roide gigant droit
manouche
[Musique]
grande fête je pense que mon père aurait
beaucoup aimé 57,13 ou tristes et
joyeuse qu'on a pleuré et ri et puis
maintenant on explore la disparition
comme comme tout le monde quand la vis
une aventure et puis la mort c'est une
aventure aussi d'une dinde dingue et qui
dînent 209 et rêve tour qu'il devient un
peu
il ya une vidéo qui circule sur internet
où on vous voit dans la cuisine 3,4 à
votre paire d'arrières vous qui chante
dans quelle mesure jacques higelin a
inspiré arthur ashe évidemment il sait
comment apprennent et des musiques de
mon père
comme toutes les choses qu'on aime
finalement par exemple j'étais aussi
imprégné les chansons de gainsbourg
comme les chansons mon père c'est une
chanson que j'ai à bab et que j'ai
digéré et après aller plus loin dans la
métaphore j'ai fait bien quoi ça nous
amène à parler de votre dernier album
amour chien fou on peut entendre
marcia higelin votre fille une chanson
qui s'intitule brigade légère
vous parlez de filiation mères pères
enfants brigade
[Musique]
et mes enfants évidemment comme comme
moi-même baigne dans la musique du coup
la musique il aurait aussi un langage
très naturel mais être en studio avec sa
fille j'imagine que c'est quelque chose
de particulier
je suis juste très agréable parce que
une très très bonne voie et j'aime
beaucoup sa voix sinon je n'aurais pas
pris pas pris parce que c'est ma fille
j'ai pris parce que la belle voix et
qu'elle était là pour rendre hommage à
une autre disparu l'aca de montréal la
chanson s'intitule sous les étoiles à
montréal
mourir l'achat de ce lac seconde
chanteuse et qui pour moi ça me faisait
une des âmes de montréal m'a fait
vraiment découvrir la ville de
l'intérieur comme c'est une chanson qui
m'est venu comme ça de manière directe
du tout réfléchir je ne suis pas dit je
veux faire une chanson sur l'aca
je me suis mis au piano l'arrivée parce
que j'ai passé des moments tellement
délicieux à montréal avec elle
à discuter dans des petits cafés dans
les tempêtes de neige d'or qui nous
bloquer discuter des heures parce qu'on
peut plus sortir la salade à un esprit
très très calme en même temps très
facétieux très drôle aussi
et elle avait la capacité de mettre une
espèce de silence de mystère d'abolir le
temps autour d'elle ce qui fait que j'ai
passé des moments chez elle à discuter
comme ça pendant des heures et des
heures et c'était très inspirant à
chaque fois que tu voyais là ça pour moi
où tous ses amis tueur sortait de chez
elle plein de désir et plein d'idées
quoi regarder danser
octave s'approche du ring votre dernier
vidéoclip compte deux millions de
visionnements contart comme envoyé sa
balle j'en suis j'en suis heureux parce
que c'est de cela c'est la boxe aux
amoureuses sur sur eux pour deux choses
assez de chansons que j'ai écrites pour
pour ma mère donc ça me fait plaisir que
cette chanson était reçu dans le coeur
de gens dans le coeur de beaucoup de
femmes
et puis elle a été réalisée par ma
compagne anne en remercier donc je suis
heureux pour elle parce que c'est aussi
son univers sens son esthétisme et sa
vision donc je suis très fier voilà 2 2
d'après me connecter à ces deux
personnes
si on est chanteur bas on a le droit de
faire une chanson sur sa maman c'est
bien ça veut dire qu'on est un bon
garçon arthur h
merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]